you know in that feeling when you find a
new favorite song you may have just come
across it but despite that you're
playing all day from car ride slumming
it at work or school but suddenly you
get sick of the same song that you once
loved you stop wanting to hear it and
skip at any time it comes on this song
has simply gotten old for you but at the
same time there are plenty of songs and
playlists that you have been listening
to for years but somehow they haven't
gotten old are these songs really just
that much better it's Justin Bieber
sorry really over horns better than
start again okay you could say that that
is because the two songs written by
different people and the active exposure
and things like that but this phenomenon
is true for songs made by the same
people as well it's trust out play the
best song on twenty one pilots made I
know that views aren't a definitive way
to measure how good a song is but I
think we have all felt this one time or
another so here is sighs man why some
songs get old while others don't
starting off the first attribute
determining the longevity of a song is
its complexity according to
neuroscientists our brains go through
two stages when we listen to a piece of
music that keeps us coming back first is
an activation of the caudate nucleus and
second is activation of the Kumba's
nucleus the caudate nucleus is activated
during a build-up to your favorite part
in a song this is that feeling of
anticipation next that cues nucleus is
triggered during the peak of the song
and this result in the release of
endorphins as we get to know a song
better
our brains are less and less engaged
anticipating and during these peaks dr.
michael boninger an expert in the
psychology of music I know we're
thinking that is a legitimate field of
study anyways he states that a key
factor determining whether these signals
are fired off in our brains is the
complexity of the song evidence shows
that the more complex the stimuli of a
song the more likely a person is to like
it with the time while the opposite is a
case for simple steam lights as dr. bond
sure consequently the more complex a
piece of music is the more likely it is
to have greater longevity
one of the most effective techniques to
increase the complexity of a song is
using longer in more detailed musical
phrases because the longer a vocal is in
one breath the more likely we are to
sing along
and when there are multiple layers of
singing it is harder for our brains to
focus on both parts and often leads to
us coming back for that part a great
example of this is Bohemian Rhapsody by
Queen this is no doubt a classic song
and it is still very popular in fact it
is so popular that they released a movie
called Bohemian Rhapsody just last year
coming in at 6 minutes long and stacked
with layers of harmonic rhythm making
local complexities it is no wonder the
song is such a hit moving on the next
factor influencing the longevity of a
song the element of surprise humans love
to experience to do things that they
have never done before but at the same
time it is also hard to get people to
try something new and divert from what
they're used to
as a result surprise is most effective
when it combines a strand of familiarity
quitting a kind of deja vu experience
most songs actually use a pretty
standard set of chord progressions as
these have proven to be adored by us
however the execution is what is
important this could be accomplished by
maybe a unique instrument or sound that
you're not familiar with like the
beginning of shape of you the chords are
probably something you've heard before
but the use of the log drum is what
makes interesting and new in the
recently popular tik tok song cradles it
is actually the same chords used
throughout the entire song but when you
think of the song everyone thinks at the
same spot the part with the Music Box
bells and then of course there's Old
Town Road we've all heard rapid country
but never together and it is this absurd
blend that gives a song a lot of its
appeal probably the best example of this
is a EDM genre these artists were able
to produce sounds that people have never
heard before and this is proving very
successful for artists like Allen Walker
and chainsmokers with hits like Closer
something just like this and faded and
many more of course many people
absolutely abhor EDM but that's not what
we are here to discuss we are more
focused on why so many people do like
such John Roos and the answer is
surprise but surprise can only go so far
and without a decent amount of
complexity will most likely end up with
fat songs that die faster than they blew
up
unless of course these songs include
emotional appeal
as that is the third factor storytelling
is extremely powerful and really keeps
people engaged and invested we grow
uplifting the stories and we really
never grow out of this interest this is
especially true when you are able to
emotionally relate to a story and many
songs target precisely this for example
Hello is about a breakup that is hard to
get through you are the reason that
about searching others and see you again
is about saying goodbye but this is not
just limited to stories but pretty much
any song that associated with the strong
idea like high hopes and hall-of-famer
associated with success and motivation
and you may find yourself listening to
them anytime you feel down or maybe you
associate we will rock you with sporting
events and getting excited in all of
these scenarios the song evokes an
emotion that either makes you feel good
or you can relate to as a result
whenever you feel this way you turn to
these songs and they end up never
getting old so that's the main reason
that certain songs never get old there
are either complex surprising and/or
emotionally appealing but while this
applies most songs that last for a long
time there are several songs I have
exposure which have nothing to do with
any of this like do you guys know why
Gangnam style is the first video to ever
reach 1 billion views on YouTube and why
Justin Bieber songs are so popular this
actually might have nothing to do with
the music itself and more to do with the
YouTube algorithm more exposure and
popular apps like Tik Tok those are just
the most common reason songs stand the
test of time but that is by no means a
definitive list as the human brain
responds to music is so complex that you
know of people studying it for their
entire life only reach the surface of
what there is to know and plus there are
play of songs that have all these
elements but simply aren't as popular
this is especially true for kestrel
pieces like time from inception or now
we are free from gladiator which are
widely acclaimed as masterpieces but
aren't nearly as famous as vocal tracks
maybe people just like listening to a
voice better or maybe again it is just a
youtube algorithm but either way music
is an art that everyone enjoys and while
we can't pinpoint why we enjoy certain
songs it
doesn't really matter because what is
important is that we were able to enjoy
and appreciate the piece of music but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think this is just a question that
I've been pondering for a while so I
decided to make a video about it but we
will return to the regular economic and
business related videos next time so if
you asked like this video the mission
drop a like and consider subscribing if
I see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one